[Music]
she's just so happy to get this fruit
dropping on her from the sky i don't
think i would be that happy in this
situation wake up sheeple did you know
you could be saving millions of dollars
a year by making your own beauty
products this video is going to tell us
how it's michelle of lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd cosmetic
chemist and big fan of diy hacks i love
a bargain i love using what i already
have i'm literally filming this using a
rig that involves an old gym towel i
sewed retinol back together by hand so i
try to be generous when i'm looking at
beauty hacks but i think it's fair to
say that most beauty hacks are a bit
questionable today i'm going to be doing
a reaction video there's this
compilation of tips from a facebook page
called beauty hacks that seems to be at
least semi-legit they actually credit
their models and everyone which is nice
we're going to be looking at their fruit
hacks like and subscribe for more
non-sheeple tips
right so first off almonds aren't fruit
they're seeds i guess this hack would
make sense if you were desperate and you
didn't have any black or brown products
lying around but what's the chance that
you don't have that but you do have an
almond and a lighter part of this which
makes me a bit sad is that almonds are
pretty expensive so you can use things
other than almonds for this so if you
take any sort of organic material
something that was recently living so
for example i guess wood or bones or i
don't know hair even if you burn it you
do get something called carbon black
basically it's just carbon sort it comes
from incomplete combustion which is yeah
even if you get a candle for example so
you could use something a lot cheaper
than an almond to do this as well this
hack does essentially give you pure
pigment which sounds like it would be a
good thing because more pigment needs
more color but in reality there are lots
of other ingredients in a makeup product
that make it work better so for example
eyebrow pencils and powders usually have
other ingredients in there to help the
pigment stick to skin and stay put and
not crease so this hack would work but
it would be like the equivalent of the
world's worst eyebrow product it's the
sort of product where if you actually
looked it up you'd see a million angry
reviews about how crap it is you can
actually see in the video that it's not
working that well and i guess with
eyebrows it's a more forgiving area
because you don't really want any sort
of solid looking product you do kind of
want an uneven look to make it look more
natural
[Music]
okay so in this hack they're putting
together some really expensive
ingredients so we have pomegranate which
currently is 4.50 per pomegranate at my
local supermarket i know because i went
there last night there's cranberry
powder which is
36 for 200 grams which i just looked up
and rose oil which is also stupid
expensive it is
360 dollars from doterra if you are into
doterra these are not really things that
most people just have lying around at
home and this ends up really expensive
i'm just kind of offended about how this
goes against the whole cheaper spirit of
diy that i subscribed to this feels kind
of like if gwyneth paltrow decided to
make a budget-friendly diy hack i guess
the main appeal is that this seems kind
of natural but there's pretty much no
evidence for any of this really helping
acne in a very general sense most fruits
will have some humectants in them
humectants are moisturizing ingredients
that can help hold onto moisture
and keep your skin hydrated which in a
roundabout way could help with acne but
not better than any other moisturizer
most natural fruits and stuff will have
antioxidants in them and that is partly
what's giving it that red color and
antioxidants could i guess potentially
help with acne one of the contributors
to acne is inflammation which leads to
free radicals which is what antioxidants
can help with sebum which is your skin's
natural oil also tends to thicken up
when it oxidizes and that can lead to
clogged pores
but there are so many antioxidants out
there not all of them will get into skin
and actually have the ability to work
that's why there aren't that many
antioxidants in skin care the ones that
are in skin care products are the ones
that have a bit more of a proven track
record so in terms of effectiveness this
is a very
uh sort of hack it's not going to be
amazing i don't think it really has any
proven acne benefits
it probably won't hurt your skin it will
hurt your wallet i think the reason
they've picked these particular products
is that they've just kind of picked
everything that sort of red and i think
the reason for that is that the red and
the dropper kind of looks a bit like the
ordinary's peel that is a super popular
product it is theoretically going to
work a lot better for acne because those
exfoliating acids will help unclog pores
and keep them clear this on the other
hand there's pretty much nothing that
will
probably work
[Music]
this is just kind of silly i mean all
they're doing is rubbing a strawberry on
their teeth i'm pretty sure using a
toothbrush with just water would work
better there's also the fact that
strawberries have sugar in them and they
also have a low ph which is acidic and
so you are basically kind of going worse
than using a toothbrush with water you
have sugar and acid and that is not
going to be great for your teeth it
probably won't be super harmful it is
pretty similar to just eating fruit but
it's also not better than just water
the acting in this is kind of hilarious
like she looks so happy to have that
orange drop out of the sky
[Music]
all right so we obviously have orange
peel here oranges make us think of
vitamin c and obviously vitamin c
ascorbic acid is a really
useful skincare ingredient that has a
lot of evidence behind it
however ascorbic acid is water-soluble
pretty much all of the vitamin c in an
orange is in the juice not in the peel i
guess what they're using here then is
orange essential oil instead which
has a few ingredients in it that could
potentially be beneficial for skin but
also a bunch that are usually irritating
they've also got yogurt and honey in
there and both of these can be hydrating
for your skin yogurt i think tends to
get overused in these diy skincare
recipes and the reason i think is
because yogurt has lactic acid in it
lactic acid is used in chemical
exfoliants it's an alpha hydroxy acid
and it helps skin turn over faster so
you get
fresher skin you get more
smoother skin you get more glowy skin it
can also reduce clogged pores lactic
acid is also used for fading
hyperpigmentation but the problem here
is that yogurt only has about one
percent usually in most skincare
products you'll get at least about four
percent usually quite a bit higher
usually in the double digits if you want
to target pigmentation i also think
honey is overused in diy recipes honey
has a reputation for being antibacterial
but again it is a bit overblown
especially if you're mixing it with
other things most of the antibacterial
properties of honey is because it's
really concentrated it's really sugary
it doesn't have a lot of water in it and
so it's got what we call low water
activity that means that if you have a
microbe in there with a relatively thin
membrane around it then the rest of that
sugar is going to suck out the water
from the microbe and kill it and yeah
that's how it works some specific honeys
also have some phytochemicals in them
these are plant chemicals so for example
manuka honey has a whole bunch that have
antibacterial activity and the ones that
have certified activity will usually
have a label on them but when you have
some random honey and it's being diluted
into a diy product and it's only left on
your skin for five minutes it's probably
not going to have any big antibacterial
effect it could be hydrating turmeric is
also really popular in diy recipes
because turmeric has curcumin in it and
this is an antioxidant there is some
evidence that curcumin can help fade
pigment but the evidence is pretty weak
it's not as strongly backed as a lot of
other skincare ingredients that we
commonly use for fading pigment you do
also tend to need heaps of turmeric to
get enough curcumin to make a difference
not just a pinch and turmeric is bright
yellow so it can actually stain your
face if you don't wash it off properly
and just sometimes for a couple of days
after you use it so turmeric and
curcumin isn't really used that much in
skincare because of that issue
and this just looks like it's going to
be less effective than a regular
skincare product formulated with
curcumin in it
she's just so happy to get this fruit
dropping on her from the sky i don't
think i would be that happy in this
situation
[Music]
so what she's really doing here is
rubbing watermelon ice on her face to
try to de-puff it and this will actually
work because cold works the watermelon
juice isn't really doing anything here
so this can be done even more cheaply
you can use ice cubes you can use a cold
bag of frozen vegetables one trick i've
heard from makeup artists is that you
can actually use a teaspoon so you just
put some teaspoons into the fridge and
then let them cool down and then rub
them on your face and that's really
reusable and i would say
a better diy hack in my spirit of
cheapestness
[Music]
so this hack is really just using lemon
juice and sugar to exfoliate the armpits
darkness in the armpits is sometimes
from a buildup of skin and so
exfoliating can help lighten it also if
you have pigment exfoliation can lighten
pigment so sugar is a physical exfoliant
and that part is fine physical
exfoliants the roughness really depends
on how hard you press so if you press
very gently it can be very gentle on
skin i also quite like sugar because it
dissolves a bit in water and that means
that it can become a bit less harsh the
lemon juice though is a bit dangerous so
lemon juice does contain vitamin c again
vitamin c ascorbic acid is a really
useful skincare ingredient it's used a
lot in fading pigment it could also
increase collagen in your skin and it's
also an antioxidant which could prevent
future pigment production lemon juice
also has citric acid which is an alpha
hydroxy acid which is a chemical
exfoliant again just like with lactic
acid this can help exfoliate the skin
and possibly lighten pigmentation the
problem is you have so little of these
chemicals in lemon juice that it
probably won't make a big difference so
there's 0.4 ascorbic acid in lemon juice
which is
really low for ascorbic acid usually
you're looking at somewhere between 5
and 20 percent the biggest problem with
lemon juice though is something called
phytophotodermatitis and this is when
you go into the sun and some of the
chemicals in the lemon juice
particularly in the lemon peel can make
your skin super sensitive to the sun and
so if you go out there with that on your
skin you can actually end up with like a
blistering sunburn which is just really
nasty and painful not to mention it will
make your skin more inflamed and that
will actually cause more pigment so
it'll be counterproductive with armpits
you're probably not exposing them a ton
to the sun but if you are trying to
lighten them i'm assuming that you're
planning to have people see them maybe
you're going into summer and you will
actually get sun exposure there is also
one side effect that can potentially
happen if you use too much lemon juice
and that's called chemical glucoderma
and this is where some patches of your
skin will actually lighten the pigment
producing cells will actually die off
and so you end up with abnormally light
skin in those bits
this is usually not very even and so
again it's kind of counterproductive if
you're trying to even out your skin you
probably don't want permanent light
patches on there
[Music]
so i actually don't mind this hack kiwi
fruit has an enzyme in it called
actinidin which acts a bit like that
papaya enzyme or the pumpkin enzyme
which is an enzyme exfoliant so it will
actually help detach dead skin from your
feet enzyme exfoliants also tend to be
quite gentle compared to chemical and
physical exfoliants this also has sugar
in it again that is a physical exfoliant
and it works really well because it's
rough when you dissolve it a bit in
water it can make it a little bit
smaller which means that'll be a bit
gentler
but in this hack it looks like they've
left it for too long so it looks like
it's dissolved and it's just turned into
a syrup which means it's not going to do
very much i guess it will hydrate skin
because sugar is a good humectant sugars
in terms of chemistry sorry this is a
bit nerdy but sugars have a lot of oh
groups on them if you look back here i
have my glycerin glycerin also has those
o h groups there that's the o and that's
the h and that's the reason why they're
really good humectants those grab onto
water kiwi probably also has humectants
in it including sugars and so that's
going to hydrate the feet
but again in the spirit of cheap arsery
i'm going to recommend instead getting
the kiwi fruit skin so eat the kiwi
fruit use that up and then take the
skins and then maybe dip that into sugar
and rub it on your feet sort of like the
lemon hack except with a slightly better
fruit alternatively if you want a really
effective way of just blasting all the
dead skin off your feet i would
recommend a product like baby foot this
has chemical exfoliants in it and after
you soak your feet in them your feet
will just shed skin for days it's very
disgusting and very satisfying and
they're usually not that expensive so i
hope you enjoyed this beauty hacks
reaction video i haven't done one of
these for a while so if you enjoyed it
let me know and if you have other videos
you want me to react to leave them in
the comments as well like and subscribe
and click the notification bell if you
like talking about the science behind
beauty you can also follow me on all of
the platforms and i will see you soon
hopefully we'll get some better hacks
next time